[MUSIC]
I want to start with a big thank you.
Thank you for deciding to
listen to this podcast episode.
More important and relevant to our
topic at hand I want you to think about
the other decisions you made throughout
your day prior to listening in.
Chances are you've made many,
many decisions, some big, some small,
some personal and some business related.
Today we're going to discuss how
we can make better decisions.
I'm Matt Abrahams and
I teach Strategic Communication at
Stanford Heard Graduate School
of Business.
Welcome to Think Fast Talk Smart
the podcast
[MUSIC]
I am really excited today to be
joined by both Jonathan Burke and
Jules van Binsbergen.
Jonathan is the AP Giannini Professor
of Finance at the GSB.
Jules is the Nippon Life Professor
in Finance at Wharton.
Together, Jonathan and Jules host
a new podcast entitled All Else Equal.
I've listened in, and I've learned a lot.
Thanks for being here, Jonathan and Jules.
>> It's great to be with you, Matt,
thank you so much for having us.
>> It's an honor to be here.
>> Great well, thank you both.
Let's get started.
So Jonathan, you and Jules have
worked together for a long while and
published many papers together.
I'm curious what led you to podcasting and
what is the focus of your podcast?
>> Getting that child, I podcast is
a lot making good business decisions.
We both feel that people make
common mistakes repeatedly.
And often what makes this worse is that
have no idea they're making a mistake.
At the same time we hear business gurus
providing advice often either flat
out wrong.
On platitudes,
like treat your employees well.
We thought we could just do better.
We could provide substantive
advance based on research.
In fact, in each episode, we will start
with a business decision that people
make that they feel is obviously correct.
Will explain why it is a mistake and
hopefully by the end of the episode,
our listeners will think that
the correct decision is obvious.
This might sound like a tall order, but
you'd be surprised how often people do
things in business that are obviously
wrong without realizing it.
>> Well, I certainly have seen a number of
leaders make mistakes and what I find so
wonderful about your podcast is that
you actually get people to come in and
talk about their mistakes.
And you help others avoid those mistakes
and learn how to make better ones.
So I have listened and
I think it's fantastic, and
I encourage everybody to listen in.
Jules given that you both are focused on
helping people make better decisions, can
you share a specific idea or lesson you've
learned that can help us in this area?
>> So I think that when making a decision
people often have a mental model of
the world that is static or fixed but
the world just doesn't work that way.
It's highly dynamic and when I say that, I
don't just mean that changes happen around
us continuously that we
have to somehow deal with.
What I mean is, when you move a piece on
your chess board, the whole game changes,
and the rest of the world who's on the
other side of the chessboard will respond
to that move you just made.
So there are two ways of thinking about
the chess game of life first, think about
you being allowed to make the next ten
moves without the other side responding.
You can win that game quite quickly and
it isn't all that hard.
But not to think about the other playing
responding after every move you make.
This is a very different competitive game.
It is much harder to play the game and
you have to think very carefully
about the move that you want to make.
That thought process can
be really frustrating, but
ignoring those dynamic effects
doesn't really get you anywhere.
It simply is the reality
we have to deal with.
And because we think this mistake is so
common and important,
we decided to call
the podcast All Else Equal.
Because there are many statements that are
true when you can hold all else equal but
in the real world,
all else is never equal.
And then suddenly these statements no
longer hold and they can lead you astray.
>> I get it.
I was wondering where you got the name
of your podcast, but thank you.
Well, I'm a lousy chess player.
I totally understand what you mean and
I think the focus that you have in
the approach you take can
be really helpful for.
I'd like to follow up though Jules,
what advice do you have on how
we actually can go about
communicating the mistakes we make?
>> Well let's start by saying it's really
hard, I think we can both agree on that.
>> Absolutely.
>> The most important thing you need
to do before communicating a mistake is
thinking through what happened carefully.
What in business language I think is
often called do a root cause analysis.
Why did that mistake happen and
what can I learn from that?
Because admitting mistakes is hard enough
as it is and many people will try to avoid
doing so because they experience
it as a humiliating thing.
If you go to your manager and
simply admit the mistake and
then your manager asks can you help
me understand what happened and why?
You better have a good answer if you have
the explanation as well as your plan for
the future ready at that point.
You can actually come out of
the conversation stronger and
you can turn it into a positive
experience that isn't humiliating.
>> So it sounds to me like two
things that are important there,
one is approached mistakes
as part of learning.
There's value to be taken from
the mistakes, so you can avoid it or
do things better in the future.
And then do that root cause
analysis to really understand, so
instead of avoiding and
running from it or hiding from it.
I don't know if embraces the right
word but at least accepted and
then figure out what went wrong.
Is that what I heard you say?
>> Absolutely, but
what the second thing is,
don't follow the first mistake with
the second mistake, do not come to
the meeting in which you're supposed
to explain the first mistake prepared,.
Be prepared so that you've done the
analysis before going into that meeting.
So that you can immediately give it
a positive twist as opposed to just
being a bad experience for
you in which you feel bad.
>> Well, that echoes a lesson we've
talked a lot about on this podcast,
which is take the time to
prepare it can really help.
Jonathan, I'd like to turn
to you allow me to ask
you the same question I asked Jules,
can you share a best practice for
better decision making,
>> Well he called the podcast or
else equal because he wanted
to highlight a common and
costly mistake that comes up
in many business contexts.
When you make a decision,
you have to take into account the effect
of that decision on the world.
Too often people ignore that.
They engage what I would call
all else equal thinking And
then evaluate the effect of the decision
holding everything else the same.
You can never do that.
I know it sounds obvious
as I talk about it, but
you'd be surprised how often in the
context of a decision, people get fooled.
We're going to explore many of
those contexts on the show.
>> I think that is so important to
understand that the environment is dynamic
and you need to be able to adjust and
adapt to what's happening and
not have fixed thinking.
So clearly something that people
can learn from you in your podcast.
When I coach non finance executives and
senior leaders they often dread and
perhaps even fear their
interactions with those and
finance like the CFO for example.
Because they often get
their proposals rejected or
feel that they need to do battle
I've heard you talk about this as
a communication challenge in
terms of framing and language.
Can you share your thinking on
this type of communication?
>> Yes, absolutely.
So I think the first thing to establish
is, we think through language.
If we don't speak the same language,
it's very difficult to align our thoughts.
So let's start with that.
So and for that reason,
I think that one of the reasons
why regardless of their major.
A business school student should learn
finance and some of the math that comes
with it is that you learn the language
of quantitative dynamic decision making.
How do you know whether something is
a good decision unless you have properly
traded off the upsides and
the downsides or what economists or
finance people call benefits and costs?
The discipline that finance brings
to the table really helps with that,
particularly when the costs and
the benefits happen at different times.
So I'm not saying that everybody has to
learn all the nitty gritty details of
finance, but you do need to understand
at least at a conceptual level,
what goes into making a good decision and
why quantities are important in that,
not just qualitative arguments.
Now, on the other side, and that's the
other side of the communication challenge,
I think it's important for
quantitatively-oriented people to
translate their insights
into plain English.
It's easy to make finance sound completely
incomprehensible by using tons of jargon
and acronyms, which is really
unnecessary as far as I'm concerned.
I think a very large part of teaching,
say, the core finance class,
is to make people
familiar with the jargon.
And really show them that once you
translate this jargon into plain English,
most of these concepts
are really quite simple.
>> That's so powerful what you said.
I mean, both sides of the interaction
in any communication need to
speak the same language.
We need to avoid jargon,
we need to make sure that the terms
are something that both understand.
And we have to take time to learn
the perspective of the other,
what's important to them.
I think it's fantastic that two professors
of finance have said, you know what,
we need to speak just in plain
English to help people understand, so
thank you for that.
>> Thank you.
>> Now speaking about how we
think about things, Jonathan,
I know you have spent a lot of
time thinking about how we think.
And even further, how we go about
teaching others how to think better.
What thoughts do you have on this
particular topic that you can share?
>> Well, this is going to be an important
theme of the podcast series.
It's pretty easy to talk
about best practices, but
putting them into practice is
really another matter completely.
>> Right.
>> We are emotional creatures and
our emotions materially
affect how we make decisions.
For example,
we learn best when we make a mistake and
then recognize that we
have made the mistake.
But for most of us, it's really difficult
to admit that we made a mistake.
So an important part of teaching is
understanding that emotions often stand in
the way of learning.
Of course, I do this myself all the time.
That is, I let my emotions get in
the way of learning and growing.
Now, the best way to teach
something is by modeling.
So part of teaching is making
sure to model the behavior.
So admitting that when
you make a mistake and
showing students how you can
learn from your own mistakes.
When I do make a mistake in the classroom,
I'm always very careful,
I try to be very careful, to be completely
upfront about the mistake, how I made it.
So students can see nobody
knows the material perfectly.
And it's through the mistakes that you
really get this deep understanding.
>> I think the notion of how
emotions affect us in almost
everything we do is critical, especially
when it comes to the way we think.
And modeling is so important,
and the willingness.
And I strive to do the same thing you do.
That when a mistake is made,
to acknowledge it, to learn from it, and
to help others feel more comfortable.
Not only taking the risks they need
that might lead to mistakes, but
when they make the mistake,
to acknowledge it and learn from it.
So that's really important information.
And I think can help us all in
not only our decision making, but
in most of our interactions.
Given the wide variety of topics you both
teach and study, do you have any last
best practices, advice or
frameworks you'd like to impart to us?
>> Well, I have strong views
about teaching and education.
I think that the way we go about educating
is really an historical accident that was
constrained by the technology that
we had for most of human existence.
But the fact is people do not learn at the
same pace, nor do they learn the same way.
So our traditional way of learning where
we teach everybody at the same pace and
the same way,
I don't think it's that helpful.
I also don't think we learn
by being lectured to.
Really, the way human
beings learn is by doing.
So I changed the style that I
taught about a decade ago, and
I guess the colloquial name for
how I teach is the flipped classroom.
Students do the homework and
read the book before the lecture.
And in the lecture,
we practice by working problems.
So I'm trying to teach by doing.
>> This notion of flipping the classroom,
where people do the work in advance so
you can actually engage in the material
in person is a great tool for teaching.
But I would also argue in business
settings and business meetings,
the same thing applies.
Instead of doing updates,
where all you do is recount information,
have people do that on their
own time in advance, so
when you come together you can
collaborate, discuss, and decide.
So the notion of a flipped classroom,
which I think is very powerful for
education, I think also applies
in the business world as well.
>> One way to learn
the quickest is by teaching.
And so you can take the flipped
classroom even one step further.
So in the last semester that I taught,
what I did was on the last class I had the
students teach the material to the class.
>> Brilliant.
>> So in that way they had to formulate
in their own words what they thought
the most important things were that
they learned throughout the semester.
And I had a very good experience with it,
I would recommend it
>> So
there's actually a teaching technique,
Jules,
that is based on what you just said, it's
called a jigsaw, after a jigsaw puzzle.
Where you actually empower
people to teach each other.
In other words, they're each putting
a piece together of the puzzle, so
everybody learns from each other.
And you're right, I mean,
I've experienced this in my own life.
You really learn something when you have
to teach somebody else how to do it or
how to think that way and
empowering others to do that.
And again, not just in an academic
classroom setting, I think this applies to
how we run meetings, how we run
teams in the business world as well.
So thank you for that insight.
Now, I know your podcast ends a little
different than mine, but I'm hoping you're
willing to answer the same three questions
that I ask every guest on this podcast.
Are you guys up for that?
>> Of course.
>> So Jonathan, If you were to
capture the best communication advice
you ever received as a five to seven
word presentation slide title,
what would it be?
>> Keep things simple.
>> I love it, and
I love how simple that was.
You only used three words, I gave you
five to seven and you only used three.
Talk to me a little bit more of
why simplicity is so important.
>> First of all, we say all complicated
concepts actually have a simple core.
And if they don't,
there's probably something wrong.
But the other thing is people
don't learn complicated concepts.
It's too difficult.
We only learn simple stuff.
So if you think you're
going to get up there and
explain something very
complicated to somebody and
they're going to walk away and
learn it, you're just fooling yourself.
And obviously simple is relative.
What's simple to a theoretical
physicist isn't simple to me, but
at every level,
you have to keep it simple.
>> If I can add to that, so
I think it's important also for
groups to set a culture where
simplicity is rewarded.
I think that there are certain settings
where over complicating things,
people think that it makes them sound
intelligent and makes them look better.
But I think in the end,
nobody is helped with that approach.
>> I absolutely appreciate
what you both are saying, and
I think it's really cool
that you think this way too.
Because if you can simplify something,
and to me,
I like to use the word accessible
maybe more than simplify.
But if you can make something accessible,
take it down to the the most basic
elements, you can really
help people learn.
And what it require from your perspective,
is you really have to think through
what the other person knows and needs.
In order to get it to that simplified,
accessible point.
So, it's not just about saying
it as simply as possible,
it's really about the thought process
beforehand that helps you do that.
So I love, keep it simple.
Now let me ask both of you this question,
who is a communicator that you admire,
and why?
And Joules, why don't you go first.
>> My favorite communicator
is Keith Jarrett,
who is one of the best jazz
pianists in the world.
And he doesn't even need words to do it.
I think that there
are things that music and
particularly improvisation can communicate
that no other language can communicate.
>> I am a huge fan of improvisation.
We've spent a few episodes
talking to experts on improv.
And I think you're right, those who have
the ability to put things together in
the moment can communicate in
ways that are just fantastic,
to participate in as an audience.
And be it spoken or
playing the piano, it's fantastic.
Jonathan, I'm curious,
who do you admire and why?
>> Well, I mean,
I wish I had as great as Joules.
I mean, I think Michael Lewis
is a phenomenal communicator.
I think he can take pretty complicated
concepts and make them very simple and
communicate them very effectively
>> Joules, our final question for you.
What are the first three ingredients that
go into a successful communication recipe?
>> So I would say the first ingredient
to effective communication is listening.
So unless you have at least some basic
understanding what the person you're
talking to is thinking or often,
particularly in the educational setting,
struggling with, what you're going
to say is not going to arrive.
So you first have to figure out what is
going on in the head of the other person.
So that's ingredient one.
I would say the second ingredient
is the one we just mentioned,
which is simplicity.
I think that there are certain academic
fields that seem to go out of their way to
say things in the most
complicated way possible.
And I think this just serves
as a barrier to entry for
people not belonging to the in-crowd.
But in the end it doesn't help either
the people in the out-crowd but
also even the people in
the in-crowd are not helped.
Because if you want to get new ideas,
new ideas are very rare.
And to get new ideas, you need a lot of
people to engage in the conversation,
particularly qualified people.
So why would you put barriers to entry
particularly in language to keep
people out?
I don't think that's effective.
And then finally, the third ingredient I
would say is also again in an educational
setting is humility.
And I, what I mean with that is,
in the end,
I think it's important to take
yourself out of the equation.
In the sense that in the end,
the only measure of success that you
have as an educator is how much more
the students know or have learned is
even a better way than just knowing,
have learned at the end of your course.
The rest is irrelevant.
>> The idea of listening and
being clear, accessible and
simple, very, very important.
But the last point about humility,
I think is fundamental.
And not only is it an education, but
just I think in all communication,
it's not about you.
It's about the people you're speaking to
and what they can do with the information
you're providing and there's that
understanding is really critical.
Jonathan and Jules, I knew this
was going to be fun and exciting.
Thank you so much.
You've provided us with so
many insights in so
many ideas to help us
make better decisions.
I encourage everyone listening to listen
into their podcast, all else equal.
Best of luck to both of you and
congratulations.
>> Thanks so much, man.
>> Thank you very much, man.
It's been a lot of fun.
[MUSIC]
>> Thanks for joining us for
another episode of Think Fast, Talk Smart,
the podcast.
Produced by Stanford University's
Graduate School of Business.
For more information and episodes,
visit gsb.stanford.edu or
subscribe to our show wherever
you get your podcast.
And finally find us on
social media at Stanford.GSB